hi everybody damn cyber here Alyssa be
crazy and know Ryan to be found yeah
anywhere thank God no it's about time
well welcome think he's not here cuz he
already saw the trailer today we are
watching the sunset overdrive trailer
which I've seen some stuff on this
earlier when they talked about it last
e3 and the game looks awesome I know
nothing about it nothing I've never
heard of it I'm excited this could be
anything for me
oh it will knows how much of a gamer I
am like he's the only person in this
circle of mine that actually knows how
much I really gave him know yeah that
that floodgate opened up and now I know
everything I know where she sleeps at
night Wow with Ryan night here I get
really creepy and weird let's watch the
trailer
yg of James Bond a little bit
now it's called a doobie alright that's
funny with you not knowing anything this
is not what it's like at all
[Music]
that's really angry understandably so
yeah no bullets [ __ ]
that's the worst feeling in a game oh
yeah
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
nice they're gonna show gameplay please
play oh they are good character alive oh
that's so cool
[Music]
these are from the same guys that do
Ratchet and Clank so like all of the
guns are gonna do ridiculous [ __ ] like
that
[Music]
oh my god it is like Tony Hawk beats oh
[Music]
I really hope this will do please
oh this course is gonna be multi player
[Music]
let's take the bathroom here maybe off
oh yeah
I just hope this is gonna be as fluid as
it looks to control yeah so buildings
aren't safe anymore that's good to know
[Music]
oh my god it does it says the words and
the explosions - that's amazing
[Music]
dragons there you park that so cool it
looks like everything is labeled sub
degrees you yeah great whoo hey know
when you're going somewhere then all
said you hit like an invisible line oh
really
that would be the only thing that ruins
this game is if there's any invisible
walls
[Music]
Xbox Xbox now starting at 399 this this
is the reason why I'll buy an xbox one
is like right now for this game Creed
and Assassin's Creed
I know Assassin's Creed in this game for
Xbox one I feel like are gonna be like
the biggest biggest things this year I
mean I'm sure they're gonna have more
games coming out I'm sure there are
things that I'm missing but this is
amazing not just because you know it has
like serious components to it that
actually make it really good for
gameplay but also because it just looks
fun it looks so ridiculously fun yeah
the trailer is really funny I mean one
thing that's really common with like
game trailers nowadays is like the
character if it's a comp like a more
comedic game character talks to you in
the trailer which I'm kind of annoyed
with whatever okay cuz nobody does that
and I mean I know it's probably sin the
intro but still it looks like so much
fun oh my god I can't wait it's on my
list it's on the list
now I'm doing this now I got a stamp but
I know like this and if it was on my
channel there would be a graphic right
there if you do we do the SUBSCRIBE
stuff I don't I don't know it if you're
near the channel click Subscribe
if you think we're awesome subscribe to
both of our channels
yes ELISA is over here and here's mine
over here Wow
games assorted other things that are
funded I tell lots of stories
she's got my life if my life is weird
she's got really reduced I can't even
wait I want to give a shout-out to my
friend Paul cuz I love Paul he's really
good friend of mine and he actually has
a band there called crooked trees and
they're kind of like reggae rock and he
invited me to come to one of their shows
a little bit ago and I had a lot of fun
so thank you Paul
if they're going to be around you should
see them crooked trees I'll go ahead and
give a shout out to all all dem Dan and
friends you know who you are
you know who that's for all of you
actually know who that's for good also
shout out to Alex Rex who apparently
watches this channel and was surprised
to see me on it hey Rex I'm on it again
I'll see you at work tomorrow oh you
missed the video subscribe to the real
rejects that we redid that one that was
a we're doing that repeat for you as a
favor because you weren't here the fun
guys yeah pizza
what's my redoing here I told you never
let that horns
[Laughter]